her moral system has kind of faded a
little bit so people feel like I can
take her ideas her warnings about
government expansion about the role of
the state I can latch on to her
depiction of individual creativity and
freedom but I don't have to buy that
selfishness is a virtue I don't have to
buy the atheism I don't have to buy the
whole transvaluation of values and
that's because she's not around to
enforce that anymore
I'm Katherine Maggie award for recent TV
and today we're joined by Jennifer Burns
who's the author of goddess of the
market Iran did the American right thank
you for coming to ennifer thanks for
having me so in your book you sort of
lay out what iron rands impact his ban
on American politics and you start by
saying that she would have liked to have
been seen as a novelist and as a
philosopher but actually her legacy is
in politics but that legacy is very
contested could you maybe start by just
talking a little bit about why
conservatives hated iron ran so much
when she was alive and after that sure
and that's actually what drew me into
the project I was interested in Catholic
conservatives and as soon as I started
researching I came across this it's
probably one of the most famous book
reviews this poison-pen review of
Whittaker Chambers just eviscerating
Rand and Atlas Shrugged and saying she's
got it all wrong
she's an atheist she's proposing a very
dangerous system that claims to be
individualistic but is actually
totalitarian at base and this really was
more than a book review it was an
exercise and tablet keeping it wasn't it
came in 1957 right after out the shrug
was published and it really was an
effort by National Review and William F
Buckley to draw boundaries around
conservatism which was just emerging and
just forming and to say religion is an
essential part of the conservative
synthesis thinkers and writers like an
Rand who are openly irreligious are not
welcome if you were you know maybe
quietly secular in your private life but
willing to join the coalition and not
make a big deal about religion you could
be welcome in the masthead of National
Review was heavily Catholic but had some
more secular types but ran sort of
trumpeted her dislike of religion
proposed a radical new moral system that
inverted Judeo Christian morals elevated
selfishness as a virtue and Buckley and
chambers thought we can have none of
this and sort of pushed her out but as I
show in the book they didn't really
succeed and so ten years down the line
in 1967 you have a cover story in
National Review on Iran because she's so
popular among young conservatives
despite what the elder generation says
so
there's been this ongoing tension and
effort to sort of manage rands appeal
and put her in a specific place and she
just won't stay there you know she keeps
coming out of the box so at the same
time what we now know as libertarians
who are who are very much formed by Rand
and her kind of role in the development
of American politics Rand her whole life
insisted that she wasn't a libertarian
and didn't want to have anything to do
with those dirty hippies absolutely she
called them scum plagiarists they stole
her ideas mixed them with something
different and then didn't give her any
credit and you know she was sort of the
inspiration for the libertarian party
for modern libertarianism and as soon as
she got wind of it she would just
denounce them in the most harsh possible
terms in her ford hall form appearances
particularly throughout the 70s that was
her one public appearance she'd come out
and people would ask her questions about
libertarianism they were probably good
number of libertarians in the office in
the audience and she would just denounce
them up and down and she really had two
issues with libertarians one was they
were anarchists and she since she first
heard of anarchism from Murray Rothbard
in the mid 50's thought this was an
absurd idea that we needed a state a
limited state for sure but a state for
national defense for enforcement of
contracts and for you know enforcement
of laws objective laws and so to not
have a state was just an absurd idea
unworkable unthinkable and then she also
thought libertarians were missing a
moral basis a moral structure and they
were win worshipers so they had no idea
what was right or what was wrong and
this is true libertarianism is a
political theory it doesn't come with a
built-in morality that's one of its
attractions to people you can come in as
a Christian libertarian or secular
libertarian or a Jewish libertarian or
you know Hindu Liberty or whatever but
no that's not okay to rant she wanted an
objective morality based in objectivism
her philosophy and so she thought it was
dangerous to just talk about politics
without having true principles and true
moral grounding under it so I and rands
been dead for a while why should anyone
follow her life now what's the what's
the audience for your new biography well
I think what I do that hasn't really
been done before is put ran
in her historical context I was able to
do this because I was given access to
the Iran archive where her personal
papers are held and I'm the first person
to go in there look at these papers and
publish a book based on this access so I
take Rand out of the realm of Mythology
put her in the realm of history show how
she connects to broader trends in
American political culture American
intellectual thought from the dawning of
the New Deal in the 1930s through the
rise of the Great Society in the 1960s
the draft controversies over Vietnam and
then how her legacy means she really
moved out of the public eye in the late
60s how its continued under the surface
most visibly in the figure of Alan
Greenspan and why she's really as a
touchstone for some of the most
fundamental issues about American
politics society capitalism how we order
our economy how we order our society and
what our fundamental values are so I
think my book is not only about Iran but
it's about American history American
intellectual life American culture and I
hope that whether readers know Iran like
the back of their hand whether they've
never encountered her before they will
learn not only about Iran but they'll
learn a lot of history and politics
along the way a lot of people have said
that we're in an iron ran moment or that
there's an Atlas Shrugged resurgence
what do you see as the kind of growth
area for rant now if there is one I mean
you mentioned that there is this sort of
odd circumstance where Christian
conservatives suddenly find themselves
not so troubled by her atheism but you
know it's interesting that both you and
Anne Heller who also has a new book out
on iron Rand are approaching her from a
very different perspective of kind of
here's this strong woman who has had a
major impact on the American political
scene do you see sort of your interest
in Rand as part of a larger potential
audience for Rand of just kind of a
general interest or do you think that
she's oh it's gonna be a kind of
political and polarizing figure you know
I think she's she's very cyclical so it
doesn't surprise me that with a
Democratic administration she's coming
back into popularity but I think there's
more than that happening
I think she offers a lot of things to
the current moment one is a positive
depiction of capitalism which I think
people are really thirsty for people in
her novels build things they create
things it's very tangible it's about
smelters and iron and steel it's
different from this high tech high
finance economy where we're not sure
what we're building or how we're making
money or what's going on
you know the people selling the loans
don't even know what what's in them so
she gives us this sort of reference back
to maybe a pure cleaner world a vision
of American capitalism I think it's
really compelling because people want
that vision and don't feel they have it
right now so that's part of it and then
I think she has become detached from
these issues about her moral system has
kind of faded a little bit so people
feel like I can take her ideas her
warnings about government expansion
about the role of the state I can latch
on to her depiction of individual
creativity and freedom but I don't have
to buy that selfishness is a virtue I
don't have to buy the atheism I don't
have to buy the whole transvaluation of
values and that's because she's not
around to enforce that anymore and she's
been around so much that so many people
have picked her up and used her for
their own purposes that there's now a
multiplicity of iron rands out there and
there's a lot of different ways you can
use her one last question you just spent
a couple of maybe more than a couple of
years with Iran kind of inside eye on
Iran's head did you like her in the end
I mean she's a pretty difficult lady did
you find yourself on the end rooting for
her or kind of thinking she needs to
chill out you know it's more that I feel
almost like I say in the book it's a bit
of a tragedy you know she had some
tragic flaws and I think I rooted for
her to overcome those flaws and I felt a
bit chagrined that she didn't what
really struck me was how deliberate Rand
was in her life when she was in her 20s
she said here's what I want to do and
she did it and that I have a lot of
respect for and it's almost the presence
of being in this incredible will to
power that she had in her personality I
think over the course of her life she
shut herself off to other outside
influences that might have balanced some
of her of her own inner tendencies and
that will the power but I do sympathise
with her because I see her as
a very inspiring and a very just
fascinating human being who like all of
us had had her weaknesses and had her
her flaws and so I sort of rooted for
some self overcoming that maybe didn't
quite happen in the end thank you very
much for coming Jennifer thanks for
having me for a reason TV I'm Catherine
Maggie ward